we now know how to calculate the price
to earnings ratio let's see if we can
use it to make a judgment about whether
a company is cheap or expensive relative
to another company so let's say i have
company a
and i have company b and for the sake of
our discussion let's say they're in the
same industry that's important because
price to earnings really is more of a
relative valuation you kind of want to
compare apples to apples it's hard to
compare
one price to earnings in one industry to
another we'll talk a lot about in the
future about why that is and we'll get
more into the nuance but let's just say
they're in the same industry maybe
they're software companies maybe i can
buy company a each share i can buy it
for so the price per share
price per share of company a is
10
price per share of company b is 20
so remember just this information alone
does not tell me that a is cheap and b
is expensive and we learned that in our
first video
and let's say that is 2008 earnings 2008
earnings
company a
made one dollar per share one dollar of
eps this is earnings
per share not total earnings to figure
out total earnings we would take this
number and multiply by the number of
shares
and let's say company b made
five dollars per share
five dollars eps earnings per share so
what are their respective price to
earnings ratios
price
to earnings
company a is 10 the price is 10 the
earnings is 1. so 10 divided by one is
ten
company b
the price is twenty the earnings are
five twenty divided by five
is
four
so just when you look at it
superficially right here when you take
price to earnings and actually just as a
little aside whenever someone says the
price of price to earnings ratio is 10
or the price to earnings for company b
is for the first thing you should ask is
what earnings are you using are using
historical earnings are using the past
12 month 12 month earnings are using
future earnings in this case we use last
year's earnings we use 2008 earnings and
that's a key thing and we'll talk about
that if we have time a little bit more
in this video but so based on 2008
earnings the price to 2008 earnings for
company a is 10
priced
to 2008 earnings for company b is four
so for every for every uh dollar of
earnings per year if you believe that
the 2008 earnings are indicative you're
paying four dollars here for every
dollar of earnings here you're paying
ten dollars so based on that this looks
cheaper
this looks cheaper
right load low price to earnings ratio
implies that it's cheaper for the same
earnings you're paying a lower price for
every dollar of earnings you're paying
four dollars for every dollar earnings
here you're paying 10
so it looks like it's cheaper
and if everything was equal if these
companies really were equal in terms of
their capital structure in terms of how
much debt they had in terms of their
growth rate in terms of the risk in
terms of the markets they operate in in
terms of who are their customers and and
how much of a competitive advantage they
have if all of those things were
completely completely identical you
would be correct you would be correct
that this would that company b was
cheaper and notice that it's it's the
complete opposite of just the
superficial price the price here company
b was more but when you look at the
price to earnings ratio you say company
b is cheaper now immediately if you were
to see this in the real market where you
see two identical companies and one or
you think they're identical companies
and one is trading at a lower multiple
or lower price to earnings multiple than
the other you should be very suspicious
there's some chance that just you're the
first person to notice this discrepancy
and then in that case you should go and
and buy company b and if you're into
shorting things you could short company
a and you could make a lot of money but
you should be very suspicious it's kind
of like the classical you know two
economists walking down the street and
they see a they see a twenty dollar bill
they see a twenty dollar bill and one
economy said hey well you know why don't
i pick up the twenty dollar bill and it
says no you silly how can you be an
economist it clearly isn't a 20 bill
because if it was someone else would
have picked it up before us that markets
don't allow just free money to be
sitting around there and if these
companies were truly
identical this discrepancy would be free
money and the first person to see it
would start buying company b and the
price would move up and and maybe people
would short company a and the price
would move down and that would happen
very quickly in today's public markets
and at some point these price to
earnings ratio should be equal if and
this is a big if
if these companies really are equal in
terms of their earnings potential and
their risks and their growth but let me
ask you a question let's say that we
don't know that they're truly equal
why would someone still be pit willing
why would someone be willing to pay a
price to earnings ratio of 10 for
company a
and and pass up or maybe not want to buy
company b even though they're paying
only a price to earnings ratio for why
would they rather pay ten dollars for
every one dollar of earnings in 2008 as
opposed to four dollars of every
earnings
in 2008 every dollar of earnings
and we touched on it in the last video
maybe they think company a is a lot
safer it's closer to a you know like a
bank account that you know company b
sure it made five dollars in earnings
but that is risky you don't know every
year you know maybe one year makes five
dollars maybe the next year it loses
five dollars while company is is more
steady so that's one reason now the
other reason is this was just 2008
earnings but just one year of earnings
really don't capture what's happening at
a company company could do really good
one year really bad the next it might be
shrinking it might be growing and this
is the important thing and it there's
always this temptation in investing to
always look back to see what happened to
the stock in the past or how much did
the company earn in the past or how much
did it grow in the past but that's all
irrelevant that's already in the stock
that's already happened whatever money
was there to be made has already been
made you always have to be looking
forward so let's we said this is 2008
earnings but let's say that 2009
earnings the picture looks a little bit
different let me draw this here so let's
say 2009
in 2009
2009 eps so this is a and this is b
a is expected to make
a is expected to make
two dollars per share
and b is also expected
to make i don't know let's say b
continues to make
let's say b is going to make four
dollars per share
so now if you took the price to earnings
ratio on 2009 earnings some of which is
behind us i'm making this video in
august of 2009 so we know half the year
but the the other part of this number is
kind of a projection you know hopefully
uh diligent and intelligent people have
come up with this estimate so oftentimes
you you'll see this is a 2009 estimate
eps this is the people's best guess but
here the price
the price to earnings for 2009
then become to see if i'm paying 10
today for two dollars earnings of 2009
the price to earnings
of five
for company a well for company b
it's a price earnings 20 divided by four
it's also a five
so notice now when you look at 2009
earnings they look pretty similar so
although when you looked back at 2008
earnings company a looked expensive
higher price to earnings in company b
but then when you look at the current
earnings they look they look similar now
why
the question was why would someone want
to pay more for company a
well or you know why would they choose
company a over this this analysis i just
said said oh based on 2009 they look it
looks neutral they their price earnings
ratio are the same for every dollar in
earnings you're paying five dollars
but notice a trend in 2008
they made a dollar then they made two
dollars in 2009 and maybe there are some
estimates for 2010 maybe in 2000 or
maybe you can make your own estimate so
maybe in 2010 people saying this company
company a has a great product it's
growing the market's growing maybe in
2010 company a is going to make 2.50
it's going to grow another 25 percent in
in 2010 maybe its growth rate slows a
little bit but it's going to continue to
grow while company b it went from five
dollars of earnings in 2008 to four
dollars in 2009 and maybe maybe it
shrinks a little bit maybe it shrinks in
half maybe it goes to two dollars in
2010
so now if you do a priced earnings on
2010
on 2010 earnings so this is you know 18
months out from when this video is being
made all of a sudden your price to
earnings
your priced earnings of relative to 2010
earnings is four for company a
and it's
10 for company b so now we've switched
places now company b
looks more expensive on 2010 earnings
and company a looks downright cheap and
this is an important thing to realize is
that in the in a present period
you are willing to pay a higher price to
earnings ratio
if the company is growing and you're
going to pay a lower priced earnings
ratio if the company isn't growing so
growth is the other reason why you're
willing to pay a higher price to
earnings ratio a good exercise when you
let's say you see a company
sometimes someone might look at a
company and
let's say there's you know let's say
company c
it's trading at a hundred dollars
it's trading at a hundred dollars and
let's say for 2009
people expect it's going to make
people expect it's going to make one
dollar
so a lot of people immediately will
figure out the price to earnings based
on 2009 estimated earnings remember it's
always important to know what the e is
this is 2009 estimates
2009. they'll say this is a 100 price to
earnings ratio that's crazy i would
never pay that's an expensive company
maybe they'll even short it there which
is it can be a very foolhardy thing to
do if you're not careful
but the what you might say oh no no
don't short it just yet think about this
company is growing so fast based on my
projections they've just really tapped
into this market they have this
intellectual property no one can compete
with them in 2010 there i i expect this
company to double every year or let's
say i expect them to grow a hundred
percent every year for the next three
years and the other person says oh fine
okay in 2010 if they're going to double
they're going to make two dollars
well that's still a price to earnings
based on 2010
2010 of see 100 divided by 2 is 50.
you're like that's still expensive
that's still way more expensive than
most companies the average price to
earnings ratio in the market right now i
believe 17 or 18. why would i pay 50
times 2010 earnings i'm really going in
the forward and we all know if you've
watched the present value videos that
money in the future earnings in the
future are worth less than earnings
today but you say no but you know these
guys are growing so fast in 2011
2011 they're gonna make four dollars
and then all of a sudden the price to
earnings ratio is starting to look
a little bit better
25
and then you could say not only that but
in 2012 i'm so confident that these guys
have tapped into this huge market
they're gonna make eight dollars per
share they're just going to keep
doubling all the way into 2012. and now
all of a sudden you're trading at 12 and
a half times
2012 earnings and then if that growth
were to continue and this is an
important point the growth has to
continue that growth can't you can't
just say oh something's growing 100 for
one year i'm willing to pay a hundred
times that because if it grows a hundred
percent for one year and then stops
growing there's no way that you would
want to pay 50 times earnings for
something that's not growing in the
future but if it keeps growing at 100
per year for five years
then it actually might seem interesting
so in 2013
they'll be making 16
and then we're looking at a six and you
know six and change priced earnings
which is downright cheap
so the debate on whether you're willing
to pay you know when you look at a price
to earnings ratio of a hundred a lot of
people will have a knee-jerk reaction
say that is unbelievably expensive the
market is crazy why on earth would
anyone pay a hundred and the reason that
they're paying 100 if they're not
speculators and obviously most people in
the market are
is that they believe that this company
is growing very fast let's say in this
case 100 a year in order to justify this
they have the company has to grow that
fast for many many many years so in this
case maybe at least five or six years
then all of a sudden this doesn't seem
that crazy for a company that's growing
a hundred percent a year for five or six
years this is actually a good deal if
it's growing 100 a year for 20 years
this is actually a very good deal
obviously a six price to earnings of 20
times 2013 earnings isn't as good as a
six price to earnings of 2010 because
earnings in the future aren't as worth
as much as earnings today and you can
watch the present value video but give
or take a hundred percent growth is much
larger than what most discount rates
would be so this is a good way to think
about it the reason why you were why
you're willing to pay a higher price to
earnings is for growth and even more for
growth that will continue and that you
think has a very high likelihood of
occurring
and then the other reason is you think
there's very low risk and we touched on
that in the first video when we talked
about bank accounts and why someone's
willing to pay a 50 price to earnings
essentially for a bank account
and one last point and i'll just touch
on this at the end of the video it's a
little bit of technical but a lot of
people you know there's kind of a
general rule of thumb that if a company
is not doing anything it's just stable
safe not moving up or down that you're
will that you know of kind of a fair or
cheap price to earnings is 10 times you
know 10 times this year or last year 10
times earnings
and you might wonder where does that
come from why isn't it not nine times
earnings or 12 times earnings and that's
actually a very good question there's
actually no obvious reason why it isn't
9 or 11 or 12. it's just 10 because one
this is a nice round number and also if
you were to take an earning stream so if
you were to take you know if a company
in 2009
2010
2011 2012. it just kept going and if it
had an earnings stream let's say in
every year it's going to make a dollar
and you were to discount this back and
you should watch the present value
videos if this makes no sense to you but
if you were to present value this let's
say they make a dollar forever going
into the future and you were to present
value this using a discount rate so 2009
money that's worth a dollar 2010 money
you want to discount it so you want to
divide it by
let's say we use 11 percent as a
discount rate and actually you know
roughly 10 or 11 percent this is all a
little bit of hand wavy so this the
value of that dollar would be 1 divided
by 1.11 i just added the 11 percent here
the value of that dollar would be 1
divided by 1.11
squared this dollar would be 1.1
1 to the third if you were to add up the
present value of that income stream
you're going to get roughly 10
10 or 10 times the earnings stream so
that's where it comes from it's it's
it's it's kind of instead of doing this
present value calculation for everything
and there's so much error involved
anyway in terms of just estimating
earnings people just give a rule of
thumb but obviously if interest rates go
down then this number will go down and
you might be able to justify a higher
price to earnings but i don't want to go
there just yet anyway see you in the
next video